When I was a kid, I thought I was a bug person.
But then I realized there’s more to bugs
than grasshoppers and fireflies….
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews. My
love for bugs is directly related to how adorable
they are, which is why I’m kicking off my
list of strangest bugs in the animal kingdom
with the Puss Moth Caterpillar.
Seems like they could have come up with a
better name than “puss moth” for something
so cute! This little guys face looks like
some kind of cartoon character with big black
eyes and red lips - Pokemon come to mind.
In the animal kingdom, it’s face is actually
a defense mechanism to scare predators off.
Caterpillars are pretty vulnerable little
creatures, they’re soft and squishy....but
this species also comes equipped with 2 horns
at their tail. When they’re threatened,
they’ll wave the horns around, and if that
doesn’t work, they’ll spray you with formic
acid. That’s similar to the stuff found
in bee stings. When it goes through its metamorphosis,
it creates one of the strongest cocoons in
the world, and it emerges as a moth with extremely
soft, cat-like hair.
Significantly creepier is the scorpion fly
- otherwise known as a nightmare fly, straight
from children’s night terrors. This fly
is aptly named for its weird cross between
scorpion and fly features. But instead of
the tail being a stinger, it’s their genitals.
Beside their weird aesthetics, these harmless
flies are known for their strange mating rituals.
The male flies first attract the females by
wafting his pheromones around while hanging
from trees. When a female approaches, the
male offers her a gift: a dead insect. She
checks it out, and if she’s interested,
mating will begin - and she’ll eat the insect
while they’re having sex. Kinky.
Back to bugs I wouldn’t mind running into
is the Devil’s Flower Mantis. This species
of mantis has evolved to look like orchids
and omigosh they’re so beautiful! They hide
out in the flowers that they resemble and
then whip their arms out faster than you can
blink to grab their prey. Sometimes that’s
insects, other times it’s actually...small
bird. Dang. Praying mantis don’t mess around
- what with all that cannibalism after sex
and whatnot.
And for those of you who aren’t fans of
bugs, what about really really big bugs that
almost aren’t like bugs anymore because
they’re bigger than some pets? The Goliath
Beetle is one of the largest bugs in the world
- in their larval stage, they can weigh up
to 3 ½ ounces. May not sound like much but
like that’s almost a quarter of a pound
- and it’s a BUG! This beetle is known not
only for it’s size but tremendous strength.
It can lift a load 850x it’s weight. These
beetles are from Africa, but they’ve been
bred in captivity to monstrous sizes using
cat and dog food. Yup, scientists are basically
keeping these guys as pets. But they probably
won’t play fetch….
Thanks for joining me for DNews folks! Are
you a bug person or do they freak you out?
Let me know down below and we’ll see you
next time on DNews.